[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thanks for
being with us America we're so glad
you're here Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show where
he talks about your job your career how
you make money every day just got off
the air a few minutes ago doing that as
a matter of fact and he's here to help
you this uh today as part of this show
as my co-host so thanks for joining us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Macy is in Boise Idaho hi Macy how
are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um so I am kind of new to everything
going on my husband and I he started
school about a year ago for a grad
program
and I was in agreeance with him until I
listened to the show of just waiting to
pay off student debt until he was done
because you've heard through my full
people when we researches that you can
get it paid for by your employer once
you get hired
but now since I've listened to you I've
kind of been questioning if we should
just pay it off now
it would be forty five thousand dollars
total
with everything when it's said and done
um what is this field of study
it's psych NP
okay so who's um paying off psychology
students debt
well so I we're both nurses right now
and we work with a ton of nurse
practitioners
um
uh doctors and everything like that and
they're the ones who advise us we've
spoken to actually several that have
gotten it all paid off
in nurses and doctors in order to get
recruited correct
own the business we're able to pay for
all their nurse practitioners schooling
and so they advise to wait as well
but he's not studying to be a nurse
practitioner
yeah it's a
segment oh a psychiatric nurse practice
I misunderstood okay I'm sorry
okay
well I mean if if you can find uh the
ability when's he going to graduate
so graduate
um
or
yeah I mean if you can get the first job
and the first job comes along and says
yeah we'll pay this as a signing bonus
to get you on board
then that's okay I don't have any
problem with that what I don't want you
to do is engage in something that takes
six years or ten years for you to maybe
get out of debt in the meantime you've
got golden handcuffs to that
organization
okay so some of these I'll pay your
student loans off
ERS have pretty serious
commitments to them golden handcuffs
and so you don't you don't want to get
trapped in a toxic environment for 45
Grand
yeah that's what we thought but do you
know of any like grad scholarships is
that a thing I've been trying to yeah
they're more much more rare than
undergrad but they're there
um and particularly in the if you've got
an industry that's willing to pay
um
pay you to hire you pay off student
loans in order to get you hired you
probably have an industry that's willing
to pay into this now as a scholarship
don't you think I think it's possible I
would not expect it and and I heard your
question you were saying oh where do I
find it where does your husband go to
school
it's an online program in Missouri or
Graceland it's called Graceland
University I'd start there I'd start
with their advisor Department they're
going to probably have a lot better
handle on what is available to him in
that grad program I'd start there if
they don't have a lot of great
information then you just get out there
and dig and I would go to who your
husband thinks might be his future
employer that might be willing to pay
off student loans
and instead maybe they would instead of
doing that maybe that employer right he
would go ahead and agree to start there
after graduation and they would cover
his uh you know his schooling now
um see I've I've talked to their advisor
from the school and they said they don't
offer any grad school and they sent me a
list of scholarships and said that it
wasn't for grad school so then I went to
where we both graduated with our
bachelor's nursing and they said since
they're not a grad school program they
don't offer any either so I'm kind of
well you're frustrating trying to watch
YouTube videos sure so keep digging it
paid off
if you want somebody give you forty five
thousand dollars they usually don't just
line up at the front door and beg you to
do that you got to go find them yeah so
yeah you're going to have to scratch and
Claw and dig around in the nursing world
the psychiatric nursing world you're
gonna have to scratch and Claw and dig
okay who are the potential employers who
are the drug companies that would like
to have you uh love them because you
gave them they gave you a scholarship
and you know who are the industry
players that might have scholarship
programs that's the first place I would
start looking
um but you know
so it does make logical sense that if
there is a XYZ potential employer that
pays forty five thousand dollars of
student loans off to hire you that they
probably would consider some kind of
scholarship program especially if it was
tied to an inter internship or as you
were going to your residency there or
any whatever else you've got to do to
finish up this process uh and because
they want you to come to work there but
you said it earlier Dave I can guarantee
you Dave is right there will be a term
of commitment for lack of a better
phrase I'm making that phrase up but
they will require you to work for them
for a certain amount of time yeah and
just don't overdo that and here's the
thing that
it's not free money there'll be some
cost a pound of Flesh that goes with it
and you know what you want to measure is
this isn't worth it the the thing you do
not want to engage in is a long-term
uh solution for a short-term problem and
so you've got a long-term commitment to
the company you've got this program
takes six years to unfold no thank you
it's forty five thousand dollars shut up
and pay it off okay but if you can get
hired and they say okay we're going to
hire you for 100 and a quarter and uh
and we're going to pay off forty five
thousand dollars for the student loans
as a signing bonus to get you to come
over here because we've got a shortage
of pediatric uh nurses and and we need
you uh if you find that I yeah I would
take that yes
um unless they say you have to work
there 10 years you know I mean that kind
of thing so
yeah I'm gonna investigate all of that
but but what you don't want to get into
is sitting around based on three law or
three doctors and two nurses having a
discussion and and all of a sudden you
have a new life uh philosophy that I'm
going to screw around with the Student
Loan program for the rest of my life no
no we're going to go ahead and knock it
out as fast as possible if we don't get
something arranged as a scholarship or
even as a signing bonus coming in you do
not want to play with this long term by
the way I want to make sure Macy knows
and anybody listening and watching right
now that are dealing with student loans
and the reality that October is coming
40 million people are going to be facing
payments starting in October and we've
got an amazing live stream coming up
Tuesday September 12th Dave 7 P.M you
Rachel Cruz Jade warshaw headlining that
event to talk about how we got here as a
nation what do we do about it that's you
individually uh you can do it it's by
the way it's free ramseysolutions.com
student loans it's free September 12 7
PM Central Dave Ramsey Rachel is Jade
Warsaw ramseysolutions.com student loans
you don't want to miss that yeah if
you've got student loans bearing down on
you don't miss this September 12th get
signed up it's a free live stream go
ahead and go to ramsaysolutions.com
student loans thanks again this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
me
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
is with us in Virginia hi Stephanie how
are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
so my father-in-law um he's in his uh
he's like 77-78.
um he was worried that they have a his
father's house up in the mountains where
we are and he was nervous about trying
to keep it in the family
so instead of doing what you said you
know you do put it put it in a trust
trust and do it that way or um even in a
will he decided to quit claim it to my
husband which is fine
but then he got my seven-year-old on the
D2
so I don't know anything about
repercussions for my seven-year-old or
how to even get him off it since he is
now on it
um and we do have family members in
there renting it too so this has just
kind of made a big mess while we're
trying because we're Sterling baby step
two while we're trying to do all of this
well it doesn't affect you because
you're not having to write any checks
regarding it right
no no it was
and all the sisters him their rights to
it yeah
yeah I'm just more worried about my
seven-year-old
no you're not you're just pissed at your
father-in-law because he throws his
weight around
I'm completely inappropriate and what he
did was completely inappropriate
without talking to the people and
getting approval this guy just thinks he
can do whatever he wants to do
what we thought he was going to do was
just put my husband on it which we
agreed to and then all of a sudden he
put my son on it too and we had no idea
yeah it's completely inappropriate I
mean
anybody call The Old Man and go you're
not supposed to do this crap
we told him that this was a shock to us
and that this is not really what we
wanted and it's not okay we just kind of
it's not okay it's kind of in his way so
yeah
so I don't know that it matters I don't
know that it affects the kid
uh the only way I can see it affecting
the kid is if a renderer fell and broke
their face and sued the owner
yeah and your kid ends up with a half
million dollar judgment on him
yeah because you're drunk relative fell
off the porch and broke their face
you know yeah I mean that's why I was
worried about repercussions of my family
all right it's also the repercussions of
your husband
same thing yeah you guys now have a
property in your name and by the way
when the taxes come due
who's paying the taxes
so this happened in like uh like October
last year my father-in-law helped us pay
the taxes because again we still get
attention you pay the taxes
yeah he did he pays the taxes so he all
comes out of his account what happens
the rent goes into a checking account
keys on and so the taxes come out of
that account and it's called makeup crap
don't they
do in all Financial steps this is like
it threw us for a loop because like I
said we're still on baby step two we're
getting out of debt and this just it
gave us a headache yeah it does it
doesn't cost you anything but it until
somebody sues you yeah or until the
property tax until the property taxes go
unpaid and the the state of Virginia
decides to come after the owner
yeah yeah and because we didn't know if
we needed a lawyer and trying to save up
for that right now while we're paying
off debt is not really the most ideal
thing to help get my son off of it we
didn't know if that's what we were
supposed to do or what
um
I yeah eventually I don't know that
there's anything big hurry I mean the
only thing I can think of is just the
liability it's just it's just such a
toxic family that I don't I don't really
know how to guard against this level of
stupidity
um yeah because the right the right
thing to do would have been a trust like
what you talked about would have been
doing it as a trust yeah maybe I'm not
sure any of that needs to happen but
um I mean you got you got broke people
in debt we give them a house which is a
liability instead of a blessing and so I
don't understand it doesn't and you
don't even ask people but I just kind of
tell them whatever you're going to do
and then you do it and so oh my gosh
it's just wrong so uh yeah if it was my
kid I would get an attorney a real
estate attorney and probably on uh
you're you're the parent you are the
guardian you can sign on behalf of a
seven-year-old and sign a quit claim
deed back to your husband for the
seven-year-old's interests so they get
it out of his name yeah who are the
owners of this deal well is it all of
them essentially no apparently her
husband your husband's the only owner
right and your kid
yeah so as of right now yes because my
father-in-law was the only owner uh it
was the only owner because his and a
quit claim data is not even a good deed
I mean that's not all you're doing is I
can give you a quick claim date on that
on that same property because all the
quick claim deed says is I quit claiming
whatever interest I have and so you
don't you don't even have a good
transferable deed uh you're probably
going to have trouble when you sell try
to sell it someday so but yeah I'd get
I'd get the kid's name off of it it
could just be a a simple
um you know your kid does a quit claim
to his father now so now all of the
whole thing is in your husband's name at
that point but I just think you guys got
other problems that are Way Beyond the
issue you're and I was wondering if they
should sell the house if it had enough
equity in it to help their their
situation well they got a relative yeah
I mean that'd be interesting if you're
gonna this family's all about power
moves so if it's if he owns it if her
husband owns it I was wondering hey sell
it take the profits and put it towards
me baby step two
solve the whole problem yes or no
I I'm not sure you can get I mean I'm
not sure his titles clean that's what
you're okay this is this is it's a weird
deal yeah this is Hillbilly estate
planning right here I mean that's what
this is it's just really really bad okay
so oh gosh I just I've seen this my
whole life uh everybody around me if he
does stuff like this and it's they just
make up stuff right and think that that
because in their head this is the way it
works right it's actually the way it
works and then then don't don't talk to
anybody about it just go do whatever the
heck you want to do until your
seven-year-old grandson without talking
to his parents oh my God it's just you
know geez so I don't know I I guess yeah
I guess I would
the first thing you want to do is get a
kid's name off of it then the second
thing you want to do is you want to
decide how much you want to stay in it
and whether you want to undo all this or
not uh because I'm not sure this it was
meant to be a blessing at least in the
old man's head it's a blessing but I'm
not sure it's a blessing all right
Andrews in uh California hi Andrew
what's up
I'm drinking should I cancel the credit
warranty and service contract on my car
to get a partial refund to use towards
other debts yes
it doesn't matter what the vehicle is it
doesn't matter doesn't matter extended
warranty statistically are 12 of the
cost covers the actual probability of
the breakdown the other 88 percent are
marketing fees and commissions and
profit to the Extended Warranty company
so you have almost no coverage with
extended warranties or complete screw
job
even if it's from the actual
manufacturer
doesn't change the numbers
okay and the service contract as well
got it yeah you you what you're actually
getting for what you're paying is about
a dime on the dollar
and so uh you know in other words on
average the things it covers were you to
cover them yourself with your emergency
fund you would spend 12 cents out of
every dollar to do that so if on average
uh if the extended warranty is a
thousand dollars then a hundred and
twenty dollars will cover than what it
covers on average now on average means
some things are high some Vehicles might
have higher some might have lower your
vehicle might have be the one that
breaks down and mine might be the one
that gets zero or vice versa and but the
average is going to be a hundred and
twenty dollars per thousand
twelve percent that's the coverages and
that's what all the data coming from the
Auto industry is so boys and girls when
you're buying a car
the number one profit Center on the car
lot is the 12 by 12 room where the
finance manager lives
they make more money on putting you into
debt and selling the debt contract back
to Ford Motor credit or back to your
local bank and putting you into one of
these stupid butt extended warranties
than they do on the sale of the vehicle
the number two profit Center is the
garage
way down the list on the car lot of
where they actually make money is the
selling of the car
the actual profit on the car not much
it's the way they get you into finances
and into extended warranties and into
the garage where they make all their
money this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today Mark is
with us Mark is in Atlanta Georgia hey
Mark how are you
hey good afternoon uh for for me here uh
great to talk to you and Ken I'm 56
years old I have a 47 year old wife
three boys just got laid off
unexpectedly from a 250k per year job
but I'd have it for at least a couple
more years uh he had net worth over 3
million
of that 1.5 million and now in an IRA
half a million in funds in stocks and a
one million dollar paid for house
no debt whatsoever
my question is is well for one does that
seem like enough to retire on if need be
but I'm also thinking about pursuing
teaching
um so I'm not going to be able to get
any cash I have 100 you know 150 000 in
cash and I can't tap my IRA until I'm 59
and a half so two and a half million in
investment's not an IRA
I do okay and uh I could thank you but I
don't really
I don't really want to use that though I
mean my I had a financial advisor you
know recommend you know to happen my
mortgage temporarily because it'd be
cheaper than you know than tapping the
IRA oh you're a financial I know dumb
butt
you're kidding me he's telling you to go
into debt and you have a three million
dollar net worth with a half a million
dollar Investment Portfolio this
non-retirement just use your money man
why you want to just sell sell stocks
pay taxes and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay well let's not forget Martin you
told us briefly you wanted to teach so
you're not teaching for free so based on
your financial situation how much money
do you need to make to where you
wouldn't even have to tap any of that
money or very little
yeah I mean that's that's what I'm
wondering I mean I think we'll need you
know I got three boys you know soon to
be College most of that's going to be
handled already but um you know but you
know the teaching is going to take a
little while to get certified and that's
probably a 56 000 a year job that's
correct that's more you know almost you
know more like a little volunteer work
why are you so would you have wanted to
transition to teaching uh it's
interesting you said I was hoping to do
that for a couple more years had you
already begun to think I'm going to keep
my quarter of a million dollar job uh
for two three more years then going to
teaching was that already the plan
before the layoff
yeah absolutely just uh you know I want
to give back I'm an army veteran what
were you doing
you made my job yeah
it was institutional Capital markets
here's a question I have I just wonder
why you aren't looking to get back in
the game making about the same maybe
even more uh and and and get back on
track with the plan you already had it
just feels like you've accepted this
idea that well I got laid off two or
three years earlier than my ideal
timeline and so now all I can do is draw
some retirement here and I just wonder
why not get back in the game
yeah it's either that or you know start
getting into teaching which will take a
year or two to get certified
teaching certificate yeah
don't go make a half million dollars
while you're getting your teaching
certification 250 a year it'll take you
know it'll take a half a year or so to
get a job and how do you know if I can
find one
because I've been looking around a
little bit yeah
um when did you get laid off
uh a month ago yeah okay
when you say look it around what does
that mean and I mean specifically what
do you what are you doing actively
talking to people that are in the
industry I mean basically what I did was
a very unique Capital markets job and
it's not easily replaceable all right um
it's something that um you know it
basically is some of it's going to be
automated in some of it's you know just
managed uh managed away okay so so hold
on a second so I can hear it all over
you you feel like I was so Niche I can't
do anything else and that's not true you
have skills and experience that were
related to a very specific job that are
transferable in a similar industry yes
or no
uh yes
then again I oh yeah I mean listen let
me acknowledge something mark
the the data says that losing a job
being laid off has the same
psychological and emotional impact on us
as losing a loved one so that was a
month ago and so I want to make sure
that it doesn't feel like I'm pushing
you too hard here I think this has
rocked your world it's throwing your
timeline off and it's understandable and
so you've got a process and heal from
this but I think part of the residue
that's on you from this real loss is
that you think that you are extremely
limited and if you hear nothing else
from me and Dave you're not limited
you've you're 56 you're not 96. you got
a lot of skills a lot of experience and
dare I say you have a lot of connections
too yes or no
absolutely mark
I I I I want you to feel a hug through
the phone here you got to get back in
there man you got a lot to offer and I
think this plan you have and by the way
thank you for serving our country you're
a great American yes you're a great
American and you've got a lot to give
still
I Dave that's what I'm feeling it's okay
let's say that I'm called immediately to
teach can I hear what you're doing that
sounds good you're not you're escaping
to it
that's you waving a white flag
because you're hurting
well if you were called immediately to
teach you would have quit and gone got
your teaching certificate you got laid
off and then decided and then you're
going to try to tell me you're called
I'm not buying it
yeah I hear you
okay but but here's the deal Mark even
if you don't want to go the route of get
back on the path to a two to three year
plan what Dave and I are saying is go
get gainfully employed make as much
money as possible don't just fall back
on that retirement
reserved million but we're not borrowing
on a HELOC absolutely we probably need a
new financial advisor
um the um okay so let me ask you this
I'm curious okay
um
what is it that you're wanting to teach
and why
[Music]
ultimately I want to teach a high school
business and finance because I have so
much to give and so much knowledge
that's going to waste if I don't give it
back
what would be wrong at the college level
uh I'm not interested you know it's it
it's uh it's definitely harder more you
know it would be more more uh strenuous
on me I don't want to go into that type
of environment I like kids that are
still molded you know that are in their
you know in their teens you know as an
old army Sergeant you know I feel like
uh you know I can be a you know a stake
in the ground as far as right and wrong
to a lot of these kids
one of my favorite Finance professors
teaching real estate syndication in my
senior year was teaching a graduate
level class that I jumped over and took
even though I wasn't doing grad work was
a practitioner like you
he hadn't he was not a PhD he was not a
certified Professor he stepped over and
taught uh three different high-end
Finance classes to college seniors when
I was in college and to this day I
remember that guy
and we I actually he actually had a
cookout for the class at his house we
went to his house I can drive to his
house right now and that was 43 years
ago I bet he doesn't live there anymore
but uh but I mean I I think you might be
that guy and oh by the way that pays a
lot more 56 000 a year yeah that's for
sure
um and uh honestly the stuff that you
know
uh High School seniors can't comprehend
uh the stuff you've been doing uh it's
it's graduate level and uh senior
Finance level stuff you can go do this
if you want to
um I'm just challenging the overarching
thing that this is what giving back
necessarily means so um if you want to
teach basic financial literacy
um hey we'll give you Financial Peace uh
uh we'll give you the foundations and
personal finance the high school
curriculum that's been taught in 48 of
the high schools and you can go teach it
for your high school once you get
certified to be a math teacher but it
seems a little crazy to me that a guy
that is as qualified as you has to go
get certified to teach math to seniors
in high school
because you can do math in your sleep
yeah well we want you to hear Mark is
you've got options and you felt like a
guy you present like a guy who doesn't
have many options and one option you
don't have is a HELOC that is absolutely
unnecessary and uh heal from this get
your head up shoulders back and look at
some options to get back on that two to
three year plan I think things are going
to develop as you begin to look for them
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us America we're glad you were here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five William is with us in
Columbus Ohio hi William how are you
I'm doing good buddy how are you doing
today better than we deserve sir how can
we help
yes sir so um I'm 30 years old my wife
and I together we make about 135 000 a
year
um I paid off my student loans last year
my why I've now inherited my wife's
student loans which is a shy of twenty
one thousand dollars
um the only debt that I have is my car
payment and I got about ninety four
thousand dollars in our bank
um just looking for some advice do we
pay off our student loans
um and you know with the cash that we
have and then invest the rest of them or
do we or do we you know make the
payments on it and and try to try to pay
it off within the next couple years when
did you get married or cash
uh we got married in 2020
. so how come it took two years for you
to inherit your wife's student loans
three years we kind of we kind of sat
around during the pause and um wasn't
really too smart you're missing my point
I'm messing with you I'm sorry so you
you inherited your wife's student loans
the day you got married okay that's what
I'm trying to tell you so you've had
those all along they didn't just show up
that's what I was trying to figure out
now how much are they what's the balance
on the student loan
um I think it's uh twenty thousand six
hundred okay and the balance on your
stupid car
uh 33 000. I I'm making double payments
on my payments right now to
um offset the interest at the end of the
by a loan all right well William uh what
we have done here for 30 plus years is
try to figure out and help folks like
you figure out what the shortest
distance between where you are right now
and uh having a million dollar net worth
and being wealthy okay yes sir and what
we've determined is over the years that
the most powerful wealth building tool
that anyone has or most anyone has is
their income
and when you give your income to car
companies and student loan companies
instead of putting it into your 401k and
in mutual funds you slow down and you
limit the speed by which you become
wealthy does that make sense
it does absolutely so that has led us to
be the get out of debt people although
really what we are is the get rich
people and the fastest way to do that's
get you out of debt okay
um and so that's the Paradigm through
which or the decision making framework
through which we answer your question so
knowing what I know now
uh having gone broke and lost everything
in my 20s and then you got the
opportunity after becoming a millionaire
from nothing and then becoming a
millionaire now a multi-millionaire
again uh and having coached more people
into million dollar net worths and
probably anybody out there what would I
do knowing all of that if I woke up in
your shoes that's the way we answer
questions is that okay
yes sir based on that I would pay off
your car and pay off your student loan
as soon as you get off the phone
okay you have ninety four thousand you
only owe uh what 43 53 000.
you still got 40 000 bucks now what we
teach the process we teach is called the
baby steps and the first baby step is
save a thousand dollars well you've
obviously done that one the second baby
step is to become debt free everything
but your house you're gonna do that when
you get off the phone and you're gonna
have 40 000 bucks left over does that
sound about right
yes sir okay and we're also looking to
become first-time home buyers as well
that's wonderful and then the third step
baby step three is to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
for you guys that's probably around 20
25 Grand okay so of the 40 we're gonna
set aside 20 and that's going to leave
you 20 in your down payment fund now you
have no payments except your rent and
your budget and you're gonna start
living on a detailed budget so you can
squeeze as much out of it and add to
that fifteen thousand dollar down
payment fund as fast as you can next
spring you should be able to put down a
really nice down payment on a home next
spring
yes my wife and I are actually able to
put back in our savings account uh
because I actually just got a nice uh
bump in my pay
um we're putting it back about 2800 a
month and that's after me contributing
plus a car payment I think we used to
have plus a student loan payment that
you used to have
yes we just got rid of those so you're
gonna be able to save 3 500 to 4 000 a
month and adding that to fifteen
thousand dollar down payment fund
leaving a twenty thousand dollar
emergency fund alone and you're debt
free uh puts you into a really nice down
payment next spring
and awesome then be putting 15 so this
is how this plan works it just Smooths
everything out a lot of Peace involved a
lot of stability involved no stress uh
but leaning in and doing this so I think
you're actually going to do this it
sounds good I want to I'm going to send
you a copy of the book The Total Money
Makeover 12 million people have read it
and uh or more told me people bought it
I don't know if all of them read it but
some people read more some books got
read by more than one person so I think
we're good you've heard a lot of stories
of how they bought it or it was given to
someone who bought it and turned into a
really nice coaster and then shows up
miraculously at the right time when
they're ready sitting on the coffee
table for four years until you know
anyway all that aside we're going to
give you a copy of it and uh you enjoy
it it'll give you the details on how to
work exactly why I said what I said and
where where we tell you to go step by
step by step by step and dude you really
ought to be uh have your first million
dollar net worth within about uh
probably five to six years from right
now if you'll follow the stuff that we
teach because you had a really good
start you're a great saver you had 94
000 bucks that's somebody was a great
saver you were the wife or both of you I
mean that he's got the discipline and to
your point any teachable you know when
we tell people sometimes to liquidate
and I shouldn't say liquidate but to
take a large chunk of money they've been
saving to actually kill debt it freaks
him out he didn't feel that way to me he
was like he didn't Flinch okay all right
he's what's known as William is
coachable yes coachable is a good thing
uh coachable will get you hired at
Ramsey and keep you hired at Ramsey
being uncomfortable will cause neither
of those things to happen and by the way
that's usually out in the real world too
you know hello for real open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Nicole is in Indianapolis hi Nicole
how are you
hi Dave I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve what's up
I am calling because my husband and I
are working on paying off our debts
um and he had wondered if it would be a
good idea to stop contributing to our
401k
to pay off until the debt is paid off
how much debt do you have
uh we have 50 000 in consumer and then
our mortgage no just your mortgage I
mean just your consumer okay and what's
your household income
um he makes about a hundred thousand a
year I'm a stay-at-home mom and how much
debt have you paid off so far
we just recently started tackling it
hardcore
um after we had our daughter so in the
last four weeks we've paid off about a
thousand
okay all right so if you pay off uh 25
000 a year
that's two thousand a month okay which
you should be able to do on a hundred
thousand income uh that takes you two
years to be debt free does that make
sense
yes okay obviously if you pay more
you'll be out of debt faster and we
tighten this Budget on down and do get
after it I like it I like it so let's do
it you know so uh now we do teach even
though it's mathematically incorrect on
the surface it's actually not
mathematically incurred but on the
surface it seems to be to stop all
investing temporarily because we have
found the power of focus completely
focusing all pointing all of your guns
at one aim point and let's get out of
debt the power of focusing to get you
out of debt actually mathematically
supersedes what you will have gained on
those investments in that two-year
period of time it wouldn't for 20 years
but it will for two years
so I want you guys to be on beans and
rice rice and beans no vacations no
eating out no nothing do you get this
debt clean so that you can start
investing again as quick as possible
if you're going to do all that yes I
temporarily would stop
investing
for two years
I want you to get out that faster than
two years
but if you can't do it in two years
you're pretty lame
right
okay okay in other words if you lived on
50K you worked extra and you did nothing
and you sold a couple things you could
be out of debt in just over a year
you see what I'm doing so I mean the
deeper you sacrifice but so that power
that Focus the power of that sacrifice
is what gets you out and keeps you out
and that's what I would tell you to do
so good question honored to have you as
a new listener Nicole hope that helps
you get going this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality hosts the Ken Coleman
show and author of the number one
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose career and jobs expert is my
co-host today you've got questions about
careers and jobs this be your day to
jump in phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Kelly
is with us in Atlantic City New Jersey
hi Kelly how are you
I'm doing great I'm so excited to talk
to you you too what's up
okay so I'm 53 years old I'm a
kindergarten teacher
and
um I got remarried my second marriage
five years ago and when I did that I
moved into my husband's home and uh I
was very very attached to my family home
that I had raised my children so I kept
it and I rented it
and
um my first four years I had a military
family they were fantastic I loved them
they were wonderful and they got
transferred so they left and I took a
new family who stopped saying me
they stopped paying you
yeah these thoughts and they did not pay
June rent and then they didn't pay July
and now they're not paying all this
why
um because they're scumbags why are you
tolerating this
well that's why I'm calling you so what
happened so what I've done so far is I
um I went back with my realtor and
um I started the process I sent them the
nudists um with the full balance owed
you know gave a little weeks of Hyatt
and then if not the notifying them that
I was beginning the eviction process
um they're guiding me along I just know
that you are the expert on it so that's
why I called you
um
when does the eviction notice go out
the pay or the eviction process starts
okay so a week from today the eviction
process starts
tell you this really quick because it's
very important to me
um
I told you I had that was my family home
where I raised my children and
when I was 39 years old I had been
married for 18 years
and my husband came home and he had a
girlfriend and he walked out the door
like that
and when our divorce was finalized I was
upside down on that house fifty thousand
dollars I had not a dime
and he paid their monthly amount which
he paid Faithfully
and from that
I now have a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in mutual funds I have a pension
I have a job I have um
my house is worth 300 I owe 200. so I
really turned it around yeah you did
that's impressive
yeah I did good for you good
yes and so this is very emotional for me
um my ex-husband
um and I became good friends we were set
out we raised our children
three years ago he had a heart attack
and died
he left my daughter's money
they are they're young 24 25 years old
and my daughter wants to buy that house
she wasn't ready yet she was finishing
college she I didn't want to rush her
she's you know she felt young and to
take care of her at home so that was the
reason I rented it
um so you know the attention is that
she'll buy it she's got the funds to do
that
um so when you know we're not ready to
do that yet okay um so just evict the
scumbagers
show
so I just
well it works different in every state
and I don't know the laws in New Jersey
I'm going to be I'm going to make an
assumption that they're more difficult
to evict in New Jersey than they are in
Tennessee
in Tennessee uh everything's pretty easy
uh people don't pay we put them out it's
pretty simple uh you you may have to go
through a whole different rigm row there
than I don't know I don't know what the
what you're a lot do you do you have a
written lease with these scummy people
yeah okay yes I do okay I went through a
realtor and I have movies ask your
realtor who they you what attorney they
use for evictions
and call that attorney when you get as
soon as you get the name and send them a
copy of the lease and tell them to start
the process uh and tell them what you've
done and as long as you have followed
what the law says on proper notice and
everything in your area then just
proceed with the eviction and don't stop
the process for anything except these
people leaving your home
okay unless the law requires you to
okay so the meaning if they were to pay
me some money don't stop nope nope don't
don't accept money they they need to
move they need to move they have broken
trust and we don't want them there
anymore under any circumstances
even if they bring you 100 current they
need to leave
yes I feel the same I don't trust them
at all
um and my just one final question
um you know I'm paying
um sorry I got myself together now I am
you know I'm paying my uh bills on that
home I I use my emergency fund thank the
good Lord that I have one and I'm
continuing to use that I'm trying to
prepare just mentally
um for how long I might think I mean
this can't go on for more than a year
can it I have no idea in New Jersey you
need to talk to an attorney and they'll
tell you exactly I can get them out in
21 days in Tennessee
but on Jersey I don't have any idea
okay and so I my guess is it's probably
a three month to a six-month program
there but I really don't know some
states require ridiculous notice and
they require six different kinds of
notices and they require you to do it
certified mail and you have to be able
to do all this stuff so you may have to
start over on the demand letter that you
did because you may may have done it
without good legal advice
um and so but you need to find out
exactly what the process is and don't
miss a day on the process tighten up
that calendar because what people do is
is they they go oh well you've got 30
days and then they wait 40 days to do
the next thing now do it at 31 30 days
and 10 minutes
okay and then yeah right on the wire on
everything and move them out as fast as
you possibly can and
um
because here's your other problem every
day they stay there disrespecting you
there is a day they're more likely to
tear up your house
agreed in addition to this and you're
not going to get any money out of your
deadbeats probably
all you're going to get from this isn't
is a PhD in evictions you're going to
get a degree a new certificate on how to
do evictions you're going to know how to
do it now
in your state so find out what the law
is in Jersey follow the law exactly and
start immediately and don't miss a
deadline hit every every every Milestone
every marker exactly on the head and
move them and push them and move them
and push them and move them and push
them this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Kay is with us in
Amsterdam hi Kay how are you
[Music]
well we're here to help how can we do it
today
well here's my question
um I've been listening to you for a
while and I know how you feel about
taking money out of retirement to buy a
home
my situation is that I'm currently
living in the Netherlands and I will be
returning to the U.S within a year and I
would like to be able to buy a home
all I have is what's invested in stocks
bonds savings however I am one of your
statistics I am an elementary school
teacher with a net worth of a million
but it sounds better than it really is
because I have no social security I have
no 401ks excuse me I do have 401k but I
have no Roth I don't have any of those
tax advantages
so that million is pretty much all I
have what is that millionaire
um it's all invested in stocks
[Music]
we are I'm recently married two years
um we do have a fifty thousand dollar
cash set aside for the move back to the
U.S we have a fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund okay so you got no taxes
on this except possibly some gains if
you use some of it to buy a home right
I don't know
well I mean if you just got to invest
invest stocks and bonds and it's not in
a retirement not in a 401k not in a
retirement fund of any kind in your mind
it was a mistake for retirement but in
terms of Taxation it's only going to
have taxes on the gains of it if it's
going up in value you'll have some taxes
on that when you sell it I do have I do
have 149 000 in a 401k from the time
that I worked in the U.S I do not have
enough
um quarters earned for Social Security
or anything so yes that was my
retirement and estate can I pull it out
to buy a house or part of it I don't
need to pull that out I would pull some
of the other out that is not in a
retirement account okay
and use that to purchase a home yes how
much how much would you recommend that I
could pull out like I'm looking at
prices of homes and they're about 350
000 upward okay so if you take 350 000
of your million and buy a house that
means you have 650 000 in Investments
and you have a paid for house
things are there well it depends on
where you're moving and how big a house
you're going to buy all these things
come into play right
I mean if you if you stick with what you
just said if you bought a home for 350
000 and you have a million then when
after you do that you're going to have
650 000 left in Investments did I do
that right
okay so then it's okay to go ahead and
pull money out
yes I would absolutely do that because
of the large portion of your money is
not in a in an account that's going to
be penalized
if all of this was sitting in a 401k
we'd have to have a different discussion
we'd think about how we're doing this
okay no it's just all in stock it's just
all in stocks and so you're going to
move some you know you've been saving
money or your whole life and now you're
going to use some of it to buy you a
house and that house is going to go up
in value too so it's going to be a
wonderful thing and uh are you going to
be working when you move to the US
um hopefully at the moment I'm a
stay-at-home mom
um our household income here currently
is 60 000. I have no idea what the job
Market's going to be like there when
you're getting married you said right
um no recently married two years yeah
okay two years married okay so and our
current household income is 60 000. so
is he American or what
no Dutch Dutch okay so he's going to
move to the U.S obviously with you and
um hopefully move through marriage
towards dual citizenship and be employed
here correct
correct okay but that's also we're
starting that whole job market thing
there too what does he do the biggest
thing
dog groomer okay well there's no no
shortage of dogs to groom in the U.S
you're gonna have no trouble getting
that if that's what he does for a living
I don't think you really got to apply
you just
get you some clippers and go at it I
mean that's how it works it is true the
amount of money folks you need to look
this up I don't have it right on top of
my head but I saw it recently it's
staggering the amount of money spent by
Americans on pets is mind-boggling the
amount of money that Dave and Sharon
spend on a pet well you're part of that
big news is mind-boggling yeah yeah it's
disgusting
but um there you go I think I sent my
kids to college cheaper but yeah yeah
it's unbelievable but yeah these things
these things are they well anyway I love
them we love them we love our puppies
and so there you go and yeah you're
gonna
yep you're gonna do just fine he'll be
fine you know what he needs to do is is
uh pay cash for a nice little van trick
it out and do the mobile grooming
because that's the game changer if you
can go to somebody's house
and take care of the pet there yeah you
sound like a customer
I am it's a game changer well no I say
that Dave that's not fair you know I
have nothing to do that's all Stacy but
she she Raves about it yeah and the fact
that she's happy and the dogs are happy
Ken's happy Megan is in Jacksonville
Florida Hi Megan what's up
then we deserve how can we help
great
um so I have a question for you about
renting out the house that we are in my
husband's in the Navy
um we have about 96 000 is our take-home
pay and we are on baby step two right
now we've paid off almost 28 000 so far
this year I've got another 44 000 to go
and we were like gazelle intense really
um should have this paid off before
we're scheduled to move
um our the interest rate on our house is
only 2.4 percent wow and looking at the
rental market we can weigh over like
for rent in this area we can charge
between 23 and 2500 a month and our
mortgage right now is 2 000. thank you
for your service to the country do not
keep the house when you move
okay thank you for your support now do
not keep the house here's why okay we've
worked with the military for years and
this comes up all the time one of two
things number one I can rent it and I I
think I'm making money or number two the
market is slow and I can't sell it so
I'm going to rent it uh and I think I'm
making money and if you're not careful
in the military you'll end up with
rental properties dotted as a
breadcrumbs behind you for everywhere
you've had a stop this is not how you
build a rental portfolio that's
profitable you're becoming an accidental
landlord because if you're living in
where do you think you'll be stationed
next do you have any idea
we know we'll be in Virginia but it's
going to be a quick it's only two years
okay if you were living in Virginia and
you had a pile of money in the middle of
your table and you said would I go buy a
house in Jacksonville Florida as a
rental even I could get a two percent
mortgage the answer would be no you
don't buy houses in Jacksonville Florida
when you live in Virginia as rental
properties set you up for a problem
okay long distance landlording will get
you bit make your life clean make your
life simple
just take the money and go to the next
stop and if you're not going to be in
Virginia but two years then you need to
rent
yeah yeah that's what we're going to do
anyway yeah so you don't get stuck with
it in the next move but yeah and again
thanks thanks so much Virginia would be
one of the big stops for the Navy right
yeah Norfolk Virginia is the largest
naval base in the world so you also have
Air Force there as well a lot of
military transient in that area yeah and
so there's a lot of housing turnover
because of that big time yeah so that
market can get you stung yeah on that
and uh Jacksonville is pretty solid you
should be able to sell that house that
you're in and be in really really good
shape when you're done but way to go
Megan congratulations I'm happy on your
baby step two progress that's very very
cool stuff
so yeah folks
wanting to own rental real estate is
like one of the biggest things in
America right now everybody wants to own
some but let me just tell you it is not
a good idea unless you just pay cash for
it and it's in your immediate area
and even then you really have to have
the
[Music]
uh Constitution the uh intestinal
fortitude personality to deal with these
things called renters maybe the sweet
lady on the phone crying a few minutes
ago from New Jersey who had renters that
um she can't get out that won't pay and
so yeah there's a process here anybody
that calls rental real estate passive
income has never done it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Ken Coleman Ramsey personalities my
co-host today opened phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us we're glad
you're here hey if you like the show we
can use some help from you
please help us you can help by
subscribing hit the Subscribe button hit
the follow button click the like button
click the share button and share the
show share the link share where you're
listening where you're watching Youtube
podcast Radio TV and whatever it is
thank you and just let people know we
know that you are doing this because
we're seeing our rankings in every one
of the formats go up right now so thank
you thank you for sharing and we
appreciate you putting the word out
there it's a big deal to us thank you
thank you thank you for doing that
Christopher is in New York hi
Christopher welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how you doing better than we deserve
what's up
um so I was just kind of wondering what
exactly I should do with my car loan
um I owe the payoff would be twenty four
thousand dollars and I oh it's like a
1.8 APR now just you know I'm I'm a new
listener to you and I was just kind of
wondering you know uh should I
trade that in and get what I pretty much
owe on it and you know I'm not upside
down on the loan at all so I'd get back
what I owe and should I take out like a
ten thousand dollar loan and get
something obviously
you know less but I could pay off much
quicker
um so I was just kind of wondering what
to do with that you have any money
um I make about 45k a year and I have
I'd say roughly about 3 000 in my
savings okay
all right well there's a couple things
number one we're always at you know you
like you said you're new to this Ramsay
stuff so we're always moving people out
of debt because your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income so
keeping a car payment around your whole
life is a good way to ensure that you
never have any money
uh and the second thing is with cars or
anything for that matter those Motors
Wheels they all go down in value
and so having too much invested in
things going down in value obviously is
going to keep you from being wealthy too
so the rule of thumb that I started
using years ago and we use around Ramsey
is don't have any all the things with
wheels and Motors added together in your
life should not equal more than half
your annual income
and yours does
right so on that basis alone I would
sell the car the second thing I decide
on selling a car I decide is um can I
pay it off in two years or less if it is
less than half my annual income now
yours is sold we got to sell it because
it's too much based on your annual
income you got too much invested in
things going down in value but if you
could pay it off in two years would we
keep it and I I think you'd struggle to
pay this off in two years don't you yeah
yeah I would the payoff day is July of
2027. yeah but that's if you just pay
the record but even you paid extra and
leaned in and say I'm going to pay
double payments you still won't get
there in two years so this thing is it's
become too big a part of your life as a
ratio does that make sense
yes sir yeah and so getting if you had
no car payment right now think about how
much you could save how much you could
invest and so you know and then when you
took overtime or you took an extra job
you know it all be going in your pocket
and you could use it for generosity you
could use it for helping others you
could use it for building you know
building up a good 401k plan start to
really become wealthy and that that's
what I'd look like you know so or what
I'd look towards so yeah in your case I
think you're already had come to the
right conclusion Christopher sometimes
we're just here to confirm I think it's
a lot of times I think people know what
they should do and they just need
someone to nudge them and we're happy to
do that and I would say just generally
speaking with a lot of new people
Christopher illustrates this
uh Dave this is just something I lived
in my own life the car thing is so
overblown in America the car has become
a status symbol and I got to tell you
the status wears off pretty quick and is
replaced by stress and if it were me I'd
always try to move the car if it could
help me get ahead and I could drive
something that's a whole lot cheaper
gets me from A to B then it motivates me
to do everything I want to do to have a
nicer car and that's what Stacy and I
did for years and I got to tell you it
it worked out for me and we're seeing it
today I mean we had our conversation
with our son the other night uh and he's
telling me about this kid in his class
that got a BMW and I made a comment you
mean I went hey he didn't get it his
parents did not guarantee it's got a
giant payment so he came home had a
smile on his face he went Hey Dad I
found out you were right I said oh yeah
about what I didn't know because I don't
hear that very often in my house
something out of here yeah
what pray tell was I right I was I write
about let me write this stuff we make a
note here in my journal but he looked at
me he said I asked my buddy how much the
payment was 900 bucks for a 16 year old
to drive a brand new 2023 BMW 900 a
month
and this is the mindset of most
Americans
and it is tragic because here you got a
kid starting out he didn't earn that he
didn't have any money kids broke his
parents probably can't hardly afford it
parents didn't earn it either 900 a
month payment on a brand new BMW that's
losing value rapidly he may run it on a
kid that the way things look
the status is more important than the
actual facts behind the scenes that's
correct behind the scenes we've got
broke people
buying a 16 year old these people are
brain damaged
who I mean that's just dumber than a
rock no man when I when I was 16 every I
mean you every kid I've had when they're
16.
tears a car up a hundred percent some of
them tear it up royally some of them
just tear it up a little bit of
Destruction it's just a little bit Yeah
but the the number of number of teenage
cars that made it with a completely
unblemished
I mean come on and so what we're going
to do is we're going to teach this kid
that status is more important than the
fact that we are stupid and borrow out
borrow that kind of money number two
we're gonna teach this kid that you know
he gets uh
by the way the parents are doing it for
their status I know because they get to
say look I bought my kid this car and
you didn't buy it you loaned the car oh
God that's what I want people to
understand and they're gonna tear it up
oh a new BM Oh then Brandon is such a
nice 16 year old kid oh God it's just I
I am a car guy and tearing up a really
nice car is just a dumb butt thing to do
I mean why don't you just give it to an
orangutan
and give him the keys oh it's the same
thing oh my gosh I mean God
oh yeah I by the time I the car my first
car by the time I got rid of it it had
been hit on every side
or I had hit it on every side I guess I
should say oh yeah and if I the thing
had so much Bondo in it it was double
the weight oh the car my dad gave me
when I was 16 Was A Turd with wheels
it was even that color I named it the
brown Hornet because of my love of the
Fat Albert cartoon series but it was a
way of making a joke and how ugly this
was the paint was it was bronze at one
point but it had probably 275 000 miles
on it it was a stick shift his child to
be safe yeah then we should save them
from you yeah oh my gosh well oh
man
oh that's painful but the object lesson
was there he got it you know and
honestly when my kids were your kids age
and they're all grown adults right with
their own kids but it was the same
neighborhood and the same stupid stuff
going on yeah I mean you know we I was
in one of the videos I used to say you
know we live in a neighborhood where
these stupid people buy a 16 year old a
new brand new BMW and then you just
actually did experience that that's just
mind-blowing
oh God because I had to explain to my
son uh these kids that are driving this
their parents aren't paying cash well
the customer parents are stupid right so
he had he had to find out I said I'll
tell you what fine I forgot that I told
him go ask him and sure enough he had
the guts to do it and the kid told him
because the kid's Clueless yeah kid
doesn't have any appreciation for 900
bucks a month
that's a lot of money wow
so that's the point is America don't get
hung up on the status of your car that
kid that that's the way to live his life
it'll take him two decades to recover
from this negative lesson you know it's
just the the that your that regardless
of the dollar amount Prestige is all
that matters
oh you're killing me
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
s
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Angela is in
Midland Texas hi Angela welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi all how are you better than I deserve
how can we help
my husband and I are new to baby step
seven and we called the our financial
advisor to see what to do with extra
money and he suggested a life insurance
retirement plan and it kind of raised a
red flag because it has life insurance
in it it would raise a red flag it would
shoot all fireworks yeah
fireworks that would cause me to change
financial planners I don't think you get
a financial planner they give an
insurance agent
yeah
um no uh I mean who who uh
is this guy of a company that he works
for
yes it's one of the national places
one of the National Insurance places
no it's a financial advisor National
Police
okay
wow I don't know if I can say it on
there okay you can say whatever you want
to but I'm just trying to figure out who
I want to trash
um
the uh um so here's the thing very few
people recommend that in the financial
World unless they're in the insurance
business
very few
and uh so he he's if he's working for a
traditional uh brokerage house type
thing and he recommending this he's an
unusual bird
um
uh how old is this guy
oh he seems to me about late 30s early
40s
man that's unusual too then all right
Edwards okay all right it's unusual for
Edward Jones we don't work with Edward
Jones but it's unusual for them uh
because they're typically a typical
brokerage house and they don't they're
not usually peddling this crap so I
don't know where those kids do why are
those kids go doing this thing but yeah
that scares me and no I'm not doing that
absolutely not no I do you have a
recommendation
what to do with extra money at baby step
seven
yes sir yes
um I personally have been doing that for
30 years or so
um and I buy mutual funds that I have a
low turnover ratio
or I buy real estate that I pay cash for
and so what I have ended up doing
honestly is I've ended up throwing money
into an S P 500 no load fund until it
gets enough in there to buy a piece of
real estate and then I pull it out and
do that so here here's the why you do
here let me explain what that means low
turnover ratio means okay inside of a
mutual fund the percentage of the stocks
inside the mutual fund there's 90 to 200
stocks in the typical mutual fund the
percentage of them that are sold every
year is called the turnover ratio the
profits on those sales are all taxable
so if a mutual fund say had a hundred
percent turnover
100 percent of the profits from that
mutual fund that year will be taxable
follow me
right if you don't sell a stock and it
goes up in value you do not pay taxes on
the capital gain until you sell it you
understand that right okay so if a stock
goes from fifty dollars to seventy
dollars and you don't sell it until you
sell it you don't pay taxes on that
twenty dollar gain per share mutual
funds are the same way so if you get a
low turnover ratio like a an S P 500
will usually have a three to a five
percent turnover ratio meaning ninety
five percent of the profits are not
taxable until you sell the mutual fund
and when you do sell the mutual fund out
uh you're going to pay taxes at a
capital gains rate if you've held it for
more than one year and that rate would
be 15 a lot less than your ordinary
income rate so it's a great way to save
money so uh you know capital gains
growth of any kind is not taxable until
you sell it so if you buy a house for a
hundred thousand dollars it goes to 150
000 as a rental you do not pay taxes on
that capital gains growth until you sell
the house if you buy a low turnover
mutual funds you don't pay taxes on it
so it's basically tax deferred growth
does that make sense
yes sir so a low turnover mutual fund
and um click online and go to uh
smartvester ramseysolutions.com and find
the broker that we're and or Brokers
that we're recommending in your area
they will not give you this type of
advice uh they will they will teach you
the stuff that I'm teaching you right
now and they can help you find some low
turnover mutual funds and you'll get a
um an investment advisor that you can
trust but um it's nothing against Edward
Jones but that kid's given bad advice uh
there and that's that's honestly it's
unusual for every Jones I'm shocked but
um usually they would be more
traditional than that I half expected
her to give me a life insurance
company's name I thought I thought the
national one was coming and I wonder if
this young man's getting a commission a
little Kickback oh definitely more
commissions on these things are are 10x
what it is on a mutual fund yep yeah so
it's it's a big commission item but even
then the brokerage houses have abandoned
it are these people
um you know like a Raymond James or a uh
you know an A.G Edwards or a uh you know
whoever I mean Merrill Lynch they've
abandoned selling this stuff long ago
because everyone outside the life
insurance business has figured out that
you know these whole life and universal
life products are absolute trash they're
horrible
chunked full of fees overpriced
insurance they get upside down and run
backwards before you know it I mean it's
a disastrous to industry it's an
Antiquated industry and so the only
people that say whole life life
insurance is good are people that sell
it that's the only one I mean so but
this kid's only bringing it up because
yeah some somebody brought it into some
sales meeting pitched this guy and he's
young and he just bit because he could
say he got dollar signs in his eyes off
the commission so that's exactly what
happened because again I I would wager
to say again we don't do any business no
smart no Edward Jones or smart Mr
President okay so I'm but I'm not mad at
them they're a traditional good company
there's nothing wrong with the company
in general and so I do think this is
unusual yeah uh if you told me you're
doing uh something like Northwestern
Mutual well then I would have said run
yeah well that's their that's way
different right instead I'm just saying
you should reconsider who's giving you
an admission yeah that's a little
different yeah yeah oh my gosh but yeah
that that's what you're facing so uh wow
yeah
um whole life life insurance and leasing
a car
are two signs that you are 100 percent
intent on remaining in the middle class
right
these are these are the payday lenders
of the middle class and uh you know the
lower class uh generally they get ripped
off by like I mean lower socioeconomic
ladder I don't mean class but I'm
talking about class in terms of
financial inputs
um you know they get ripped off by Tote
The Note lot rent to own uh pawn shops
uh that's who's in there into town uh
payday lenders are the worst of the
worst this is gummies to the scum so the
whole life life insurance agent the car
leasing is the payday lender of the
middle class that's what it amounts to
and uh you know that's who rips them up
see you don't see these things in the
rich end of town no you don't you know
that's the other thing I want to ask you
know why because rich people don't do
that stuff that's how they got rich
what's the ratio of people in baby step
seven really needing Insurance you know
you become self-insured she was just
looking for a retirement she was looking
for an investment oh I know but I just
wanted to bring this up for new
listeners because this idea of insurance
in general my life insurance you I don't
know I mean it's based on you know net
worth if you die is there enough money
to take care of everybody that's left
right that's the formula right and if
you know if you're sitting on 10 million
dollars and you you know the kids are
grown and gone and you die you don't
need life insurance I don't have life
insurance right I'm I don't but I don't
my kids are grown and gone they're
they're independent
um and there's you know hundreds of
millions of dollars assets left to Miss
Sharon should be fine you know so I
think she can struggle through what do
you think you know so I don't think she
needs freaking life insurance so yeah
where you become self-insured by getting
the kids grown and gone getting rid of
the debts and building a balance in your
retirement and your Investments right so
you got a couple million dollars in your
retirement you got I paid for a house
kids are grown and gone your need for
life insurance is gone that's right and
so then the only time they would bring
it up to somebody like Angela in her
case is uh is trying to sell it as an
investment program which is a bunch of
crap yeah keep those in two separate
buckets one of those little little
emojis turds with eyes on it that's what
this thing is that's exactly what it is
we need that little pile of turd Emoji
James we need that maybe we'll pop that
up at will here with a sound effect man
I don't know well just put it right
there on the old whole life life
insurance right there boom right there
boom boom right there yeah boom this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality host of the king Coleman
show where he helps people with jobs and
careers he's my co-host today he also
wrote a number one bestseller from
paycheck to purpose so thanks for
hanging out with us the phone number is
888-825-5225 Chris is in Boston hi Chris
how are you
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
yeah I wanted some advice here
um it's been kind of a interesting
summer
um I was
um laid off
a couple of months ago had a really good
position as a vpa a transformation
company came into the company and took
it over it was by uh it was pretty
surprising very bad wheat packages two
weeks and at the end of the month
um popped on COBRA unfortunately two
months later after that my wife was
diagnosed with breast cancer
so what I'm trying to do is the most
important thing is taking care of her
you know I'm 54 years old and and
um you know I have no debt which is
great my house is paid for you know I
have a pretty solid IRA and I have
um some money
um you know for the situation but you
know you get concerned you know I have
really good insurance through the Cobra
I'm paying 2100 a month of course you
know how cold brew it goes
um I would prefer to not work right now
but you know with other bills coming in
so you have to just I don't know what
type of bill is going to come in based
on this because she'll be doing chemo
every week for the next three months and
then chemo every three weeks for the
next three months in surgery
should I continue to look for a job you
know I think a lot of companies are kind
of scared because I was a VP and a GM in
my age but I'm I'm kind of at that stage
in my life where it's more project you
know um just looking for some good
advice from somebody you know and kind
of get an understanding what your
thoughts are
what do you mean when you say project do
you mean you feel like you're more of a
freelancer project by project type guy
now is that what you mean
honestly I could I could you know manage
a large team or I'm to the point you
give me a project I can just you know
from an innovation standpoint of from a
strategic standpoint even managing your
piano I can go do that you know I don't
need to manage you know a large team you
know
um I don't want to of course you know
when you have those conversations
because they say oh you're overqualified
and you say well I could do this or that
you know how companies are they don't
think you want to work you know I think
in my situation might be
helpful you know for a company for me to
come in with my experience I think so
too I think by the way if you ever run
into that right now yeah let me just say
this real quick on the if you ever run
into this you're over qualified let me
tell you what that's code for okay
that's code for they think that uh
you're not gonna stay that you're not
gonna stay or they also think that they
can't afford you and I think what you
have to say is is you have to tell them
your situation and go hey I'm I'm
flexible make me an offer uh and a lot
of times we hear that people look at
someone's resume and they go why would
you be downshifting it starts to come up
with red flags yellow flags so that's
all about communication just want to
address that if you're very clear in the
interview process tell them who you are
what you're about how flexible you are
that's a whole different ball game
look I've made the big salary and the
other thing is you don't want to play
that down because when you have that
conversation I I don't know if it causes
a red flag too you know what I'm saying
I don't need to make that you know 250
money that's what you were making last
time yeah I was making uh 250 plus 35
bonus with the bonus was coming in you
know so and that's probably in the range
from my last couple of jobs well again
don't play anything down I'm not telling
you to play it down I'm telling you to
be open and communicate clearly and once
people have all of their questions
answered it's not sketchy there's
nothing sketchy about you especially
where you're at so I think the big issue
comes down to uh how much you want to
stay at home right now
and and where you stand on that I think
that's driving this next decision yeah
yeah well that's I mean it sounds it
sounds like it sounds like you got two
solid months of
of uh caretaking
three just the every week process you
know of her going through the chemo
um
you know I've never collected
unemployment before I'm collecting
unemployment now you know and Boston's
pretty good but you know a lot of that
unemployment's eating the Cobra you know
and I have
I have you know I have a checking I have
two savings and then I have a high a
high yield interest and how much is that
um
my high yield interest the 4.5 about
180k okay and what do you burn in a
month
um let's see I'm getting from
unemployment 3 400.
um I'm just thinking I'm probably going
over a thousand of that over the you
know so I'm going in a thousand of my
savings but outside I'm not touching
that I could go in 2000 that's 25 000 a
year
you know you got several years in that
one account
yeah and then I have just uh I have
another in my other two
so my checking I got 15 and 13 and then
I got some of my checking so
I have enough how did you say you are
54. how old is your wife
she's uh 55. how long you all been
married
31 years okay I'll show you what I'm
doing
yeah I'm not I'm not going back to work
right now okay you got 180 000. just
pull two grand a month out of there
that's 25 000 in the next year spend the
next year taking care of your wife sir
okay she needs you okay she needs you
definitely and you're still going to be
just as employable at the end of it
you've got plenty of money
you've got plenty of margin you're going
to be just fine twenty five thousand
dollars does not change your life
yep yep totally and you spend a year
with your wife while she's going through
this does change your life
oh 100 you know I just want like I said
it's important to hear from Good People
yeah you know you guys do such a really
good job and you know I try to follow
everything with you guys you can keep
the Cobra going at least that long
yeah I have the Cobra for 18 months so
it's a good thing it goes through
December 2024. yep so you know six
months before that Cobra runs out I'm
gonna get real serious about Landing the
job
yep before that the next the next 12
months I'm gonna ride with I'm Rob with
her next nine months whatever it is
let's get her the other side of this and
uh because this is beatable it's just
gonna be a a year of hell
to beat it yeah that's exactly and like
you said the most important thing is you
know to be by our side and we have God
on our side too which is amen you know
um and Chris you know and one
encouragement when you get back in this
thing No One's Gonna worry about that
Gap because you've got an incredible
Story You're an absolute hero you know I
got laid off and uh some you know it
runs simultaneous with my wife getting
breast cancer we've been married 31
years I had plenty of money in savings
and so I opted to take 10 months and
take care of her if you don't like that
Gap I don't want to work here I want to
hire that person I want to go to battle
with Chris I'm not I'm not that that's
that doesn't affect you at all and by
the way my people of character and kudos
to you Chris and your wife you're the
poster children for financial peace to
be able to ride through this storm right
now because they've been disciplined
they got choices you got options because
they've done a great job with their
money and um and they got a great value
system so yeah I just want to tell you
don't worry about career for 10 months
at least this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thanks for joining us America Dr John
deloney has a brand new book coming out
called building a non-anxious life if
you pre-order it today you'll get 75
dollars worth of free bonus items
including instant access to his newest
talk smoke fire and freedom it breaks
down all the mythology around anxiety
the things we believe and it'll help you
reclaim your life you're also going to
get the e-book and the audiobook when it
all comes out the actual Pub date is
October 3rd that's when we'll ship them
to you but for 20 bucks you can get all
of this stuff if you buy it early and
buy it now it also helps John helps us
with the marketing so thank you for
doing that you are going to actually
learn how to identify effective
techniques to respond to anxiety and
prepare for
anxiety-inducing events hello you know
it's real there's a real set of tools to
do this and it's this is this book is
incredible building a non-anxious life
pre-order it right now
ramsesolutions.com today's question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services when
something in your home breaks neighborly
is the name to remember and with the
neighborly Done Right promise you'll
know you get great service from their
network of local home service providers
so go to neighborly.com today today's
question comes from Diane in New Mexico
I'm 61. I am recently divorced I have no
retirement or health insurance and I
want to work in child care should I
choose to work for a big retail company
instead just to make sure I have
retirement and health insurance
uh you know this is where I wish that
this was on the phone and we could go
back and forth dig a little bit more but
at 61 uh if you can't get a decent
health insurance plan with the
retirement 401K options in child care
meaning working for child care companies
that have you know multiple places
around your Locale and certainly larger
Regional or national Child Care change
if you will then I would be looking for
a larger company to get some stability
coming out of divorce I hate this for
you your life has been shaken
tremendously you got a lot of unknowns
and that's a scary place so getting
stable right now is the best move uh
financially so you've got the health
insurance benefits so can build that
retirement as you can
it I I agree
um
unless she can make a lot more money
working for an individual Being Mary
Poppins well that's a very good and if
you make enough more to pick up her own
retirement and her own health insurance
and has a better environment but it
would have to be you can't make the same
money with no benefits you'd have to say
okay yeah it says benefits or money
that's all that's correct yeah if you
don't you know if they're paying minimum
wage and you can get forty dollars an
hour working for an individual as a
nanny yep uh and you pick up your own
health insurance and your own and you
come out ahead that's exactly right and
I think you got to compare the the yeah
but if it's Apples to Apples if it's the
same hourly rate then you would take the
one for sure with the corporate retail
yes yes but to your point and again if
you are like let's let's where she's at
New Mexico she lives in an area where
there's wealthy people in most areas
have a Lo have a wealthy uh contingency
to them they're looking for someone they
can trust a grandmother very dependable
comes in the home does laundry injury
helps with meal preparation not just
child care she can offer that now all of
a sudden she's charging a premium
because that's you're saving people a
lot of time meal planning well and let
me just tell you she's not a 22 year old
doing this that's going to get married
to have a baby and you've got to go get
another one that's correct you know and
so value there it's uh she she actually
has a is a very appealing Prospect for
that as far as I'm concerned so that's a
very good point but you'd have to make a
lot more to be able to buy your own
stuff what do you think you have an idea
what a self-insurance would cost a 61
year old I mean
you know I bet you you can make double
doing that which you can make at a
retail I'm I'm I don't know you probably
know a lot more you do know a lot more
about it than I do but in my
uh vision of working at a retail daycare
without question you're not going to pay
much you're correct
and then and she could make like lawyer
money working for a family without
question oh certainly a wealthy family
is multiple kids just looking for a
living or or somebody there four days a
week and and but you're right because I
mean what a 61 year old brings to the
table for that family is
excellent oh man peace of mind now Stacy
and I did this several years ago when
Stacy was working remember all three of
our kids were in middle school or
younger and we hired a lady who was
about this age
she can't we call her Miss Pam and Miss
Pam came in she was there when the kids
got home from school made sure they did
their homework she started laundry light
cleaning duties nothing major yeah yeah
and we our peace of mind was off the
chart well and let me just tell you the
kids didn't mess with Miss Pam no
because they knew Miss Pam was going to
tell us everything
you're bringing in Mary Poppins with a
parrot head umbrella I'm just saying
yeah I love that I'm thinking that I I'm
thinking this is a premium Miss Diane
um and you know but assuming you can't
don't get a premium assuming you get the
same pricing yeah then you would
obviously take the one with the other
stuff but you can set up your own IRA
and go buy you some health insurance
from Blue Cross Blue Shield or somebody
and be in fine shape as a self-employed
independent Nanny you know you can just
decide who is and there you is yeah
that's a beaut this is America I love it
Connor's in Kalamazoo hey Connor how are
you doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
um well I guess so my wife and I were 26
years old we just had a baby in April
and I graduated from pharmacy school in
May I'm contemplating two job offers
right now
uh one is kind of my dream job at a
hospital and
um I guess with that job it pays less
and it's further away from family how
much less
it's four hours away from my family and
then the other job at the university is
about one hour away
but how much less money I don't even
want to consider this to be honest with
you because it's four hours there is no
way it's nuts you don't have a family
when you're working four hours away
yeah you're not in the military that's a
nightmare not a dream my friend well
well so the the reason I mean you move
if you take that job
well so I guess my family the reason I
can't apply near them is they live near
a big uh who's my family your mother
these are my friends family yeah my
immediate family
you can move away from them are you are
you married
yes that's married you can't move away
from her
no no no definitely not that's what we
thought was her up and moved to the
hospital that's fine okay I got it how
much less money is the hospital job
going to pay you that's offer one for
this discussion then offer two how much
what's the difference in salary
so the salary is only six thousand less
so it's a hundred and nine thousand at
the hospital and the university is 115.
um but the benefits at the uh at the
University are like way better they have
a 10 401K match okay you have all your
weekends and holidays off okay but you
said that the Universe excuse me you
said that the hospital job is your dream
job
so you're going to turn down the dream
job for six thousand dollars in benefits
when I'm guessing there's a ladder at
the dream job meaning you have an
opportunity to grow is that true that's
true but the downside is you know going
through school I always thought that I
you know Hospital Pharmacy was for me
but then once I had my baby you know
money talks a lot and my priorities
changed so I'm wondering if it would be
better for me to take the university job
for the money at this point
I I it's not that much money it's not
that big of a deal what makes the
hospital pharmacy the dream versus
normal Pharmacy and I'm asking this
completely clueless because I don't
understand that what would be what would
make it a dream versus why is that just
a good job so for me I guess it's the
patient population that I would be
working with
um you know in school I always liked
working with the people who are the a
lot sicker and I just found that more
rewarding to me to be able to help those
in need I get that okay so if you take
the hospital job you would you would
move your family near the hospital right
correct okay
but is and it's just it's it's basically
the same money yeah go go do go do the
same money and do the one you want to do
and move your family yeah yeah and you
know make sure you've got some upward
trajectory in whatever you take that
you're not stuck you're not you know but
you ought to be able to do a lot of
stuff with a pharmacy degree dude this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thanks for joining us America Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Dylan is with us in Salt Lake City
hi Dylan how are you
good how are you Dave thank you for
taking my call my pleasure what's up
so my wife and I have been married for
three years ago or for three years now
we've been going to school going to
college
she graduated this past May with an
engineering degree and I graduated this
upcoming day with an engineering degree
we're 100 debt free we made it through
college
with no student loans
then we've been able to save about sixty
thousand dollars that we've earmarked
for a home
um and we're curious as to whether or
not now is the time to buy with interest
rate so high and with with just
everything going on in the market
uncertainty
um yeah so what's your what's your
advice for me or other questions you
have
you're gonna you know you're gonna stay
in that area
yes we are
okay so you get um
I mean you get out of school and you're
gonna take a job and that's not gonna
change the real estate decision
yes okay all right
I mean I can believe that I just wanted
to double check and you have zero debt
of any kind of 60 grand for a down
payment
zero debt of any kind 60 grand for a
down payment and about 30 000 in
retirement accounts and two years funded
HSA account good for you okay
well done well done okay uh I would buy
now
uh regardless of interest rates uh
here's what I don't know
uh 12 to 24 months from now I don't know
what interest rates will be
I do know house prices will have gone up
seven to eight percent a year during
those that time
okay house prices are continuing to go
up and pre and and uh regardless of
interest rates because there continues
to be a shortage of housing versus the
number of buyers looking
now so the the in other words the
strategy is we can predict that the cost
is going to go up so we might as well
get in now we don't know if rates are
going to go down or not so waiting on
them to come down they might not
yeah there's no guarantee they're going
to come down
yeah um and uh they they sat at six for
a decade
before and then in 2008 they were
artificially driven down because of the
housing crisis and the government just
straight up manipulated the market and
drove the rates all the way down to
about one percent there for a minute and
then up to two then up to three and then
back down to two and a half and then up
to three and it sat there for a while
and and then jumped up just recently you
know to six and seven again and uh
everybody's freaking out like that's a
high interest rate but over the scope of
History it's not really a high interest
rate so what I would say is this we know
house prices are going to go up so let's
buy if interest rates go down which we
don't know you can always refinance
you're not stuck but you are stuck with
house prices
yep so bye now
okay another question for you is in that
case say we have we buy in the next six
months how much house can we afford our
income last year was about 80 80k we
have a baby on the way doing due early
next year so my wife won't be working as
much
um but when the baby comes in I'll be
working full time so that's kind of the
projected income is about 80k a year
yeah a fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage is our
suggestion
and that's going to mean you're probably
going to buy less house than you thought
you were going to buy before this call
but that's okay it's your first house
you're in your early 20s you got time
you're both Engineers you're both
working someday you can easily move up
in house later
so again I would get into the game uh
the only thing that's now making me
hesitate is I don't know if I'm going to
move a pregnant woman or third trimester
that sounds like a hell on Earth to me I
don't think I want to do that yeah but
um but you know you might I don't know
uh the further along in the pregnancy
she is the less likely I am to buy until
after the baby
so just because it's you know it's hard
on her I mean really she's got y'all got
enough on your play without dealing with
the hanging curtains for God's sakes so
um yeah it's okay to not buy there's no
sin that says you have to buy
immediately but you know we were
discussing interest rates and prices a
minute ago now we're talking about your
life
so I might wait till after the baby
comes on my way to here
uh just just for just for comfort you
know uh there's nothing that says you
have to do it now and you have plenty of
time and you'll both have great careers
you'll both make great incomes you're
going to be debt-free millionaires in
your 30s no matter which of these you do
whether you buy before or after the baby
but a 15-year fixed where the fourth of
your take-home pay is going to the
payment and you'll be right on track get
that house paid off or move up later on
when everybody's back working and all
that kind of stuff and the other thing
too is I think he's short changing
himself as to what their income could be
I know his wife's going to back off a
little bit he'll be coming out into the
market I think it's very possible if
they wait a year that they might find
that their income is is higher yeah
that's very possible
might put you into a different house if
interest rates stay the same and house
prices went up seven percent during that
year which is probably what's going to
happen
um you know the only thing that's really
going to push interest rates down that I
can see today is the fact that we're
going into a presidential election year
and generally the sitting party will try
to drive rates down to say look what I
did that's correct
um
and they you know and and we all know
that why weren't you doing that two
years ago man you know I mean it's that
there's always that but
um I I don't I wouldn't hold your breath
because uh Jerome Powell's gone on
record as saying if when we've got this
uh inflation rate where it is and it's
still a little higher than they expected
when when July report came in and so
unemployment's still very very low I was
expecting to raise it a couple more
times they're just screwing with it just
to prove that it's not they're uh it's a
whole other discussion they're trying to
trying to use a hammer on a Phillips
head screwdriver but they just because
they don't know what the heck they're
doing but the it's a disaster but anyway
all of that to say I don't know that
you're going to see interest rates come
down so you you just decide in the scope
of your life with a baby on the way when
we're gonna buy Ted is in Saint Paul
Minnesota hi Ted how are you
great how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
I got a career question for you guys uh
so I hope I picked the right crowd today
but
um I'm in a role that I really like
um I'm a marketing analyst and I make
good money my wife and I are in a good
financial position
um I feel like I can continue to grow I
just want to know and bounce some ideas
off both y'all of how I can best a girl
in my career
um so if you're good with it I have the
get clear assessment I can read you my
career statement if that's good with you
guys sure yeah
all right so I was created to use my
talents of connection compassion
imagination to perform my passions of
promoting advocating protecting to
accomplish my mission of service by
producing assistance and protection and
so for me that's just you know my
Christian faith I really want to you
know serve others and uh impact lives to
you know help people live their best
lives too
um and so I feel like I get to do that a
little bit right now and I want to
continue to grow in doing that as well
in my career so do you have a specific
idea of advice well let me say this your
assessment results scream people so
there's really four types of work in the
world people work idea work process work
and then objects or things okay and your
results scream people screams people and
so the question becomes for you to be
very fulfilled you're going to want to
find work that allows you to use the
people skills because you have a lot of
people talents here and then you very
much love working with people and your
motivational driver that missional
result of service means I want to see
the results of my work come through in
the vein of serving people so you got to
figure out the people you want to help
the problem that they've got and the
solution to that problem that's high
level and and so that's what you're
looking for but I would not be in any
kind of rush to leave a job you like
because I want you to figure out what is
that path what's the steps along that
path to get to that work but I would
guess you have a good idea what it is
and uh so uh one of the things I want to
do is I'd love we're running out of time
uh Austin I'd love to get him on the
show on the Ken Coleman show and let me
work through that with him in great
detail as to what his ideas are because
Dave I know this when somebody calls
with that type of question there's
something in them that's burning and
itching and they're looking for
confidence absolutely to step forward in
that direction yeah he he thinks he
knows but he's not sure yeah this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Proverbs 16 3
commit to the Lord whatever you do and
He will establish your plans
Stephen Covey said live out of your
imagination not your history
that was good Sharon's in Greenville
South Carolina hi Sharon welcome to the
Ramsey Show
what's up
five years old a recent Widow and we
have some lakefront land for sale in
South Carolina and I was recently
offered a full price six hundred
thousand dollars in physical gold and I
am having a heck of a time finding any
good advice as to the advantages and
disadvantages of accepting physical gold
and payment for the land and I've
listened to you for years and it
occurred to me I need to call Dave and
see what he would recommend
um
okay number one
if this is real
you don't know you laid eyes on a big
giant chest full of gold bullion that's
what I got in my head yeah no no I I
know
but I can clarify I know the person who
is offering the deal very well and he is
a wealthy person who owns a large
company that does work in four
Southeastern companies so he's legit uh
you know not a difficult person to check
out and why doesn't he just pay you
what do you mean why doesn't he just
close the land I mean sell the gold and
pay you in cash
well I don't I would ask him that
question that's a good question to ask
he told me he has been blind gold he's a
great believer in the gold standard for
the U.S and since he started this
company at 18 and he's 80 now he has
accumulated all this physical gold so
sell some of it and since it's so
wonderful and give me my money give me
my money okay listen here
let's turn it back let's turn it and
let's be a little bit nicer okay here's
how I would handle it if I were you okay
okay I'm going to play the
uh
I I always play the uh uh you know for
instance in business I'll go oh we're
just a small business we're not real
sophisticated you got to help us out
okay okay so in your case it would sound
like this I'm a 75 year old Widow I
don't even know how to begin thinking
about doing this you're the guy that has
all the money and you're Mr
sophisticated so I need you to help me
out I I don't I can't do this because I
don't know how so what you what I need
you to do is just show enough of it and
give me my money
that I can do I because I don't know
what to do with it man and you're the
you're the big gold guy you're you're
you have all the connections you know
how to turn it into money I don't know
how to turn it into money so you got to
help me out here
uh okay well one thing that he's told me
and I also confirmed this was that there
are no tax consequences there's not
doing what yeah there's not so that's
awfully attractive when you're looking
at a six hundred thousand no there's
there's no tax no no no no no no no no
no no no there's no tax consequences to
it being gold there is text consequences
to you selling the land
yes but like but whether you take cash
or take gold doesn't matter
right there's no taxation because
because it's gold it doesn't make it
have tax consequences
okay but but there's no way I'm doing
this
there's no way you should do this
knowing knowing how much that you work
in real estate I thought maybe you'd run
across that before or you just you
wouldn't recommend it for anything I can
probably get the gold liquidated but I
wouldn't take it
right because I don't I don't need to
fool with it they need to fool with it
that's there is there the god the goal
is their issue not my issue I don't I'm
not getting in the gold business
and I don't want to be in the gold
business for 10 seconds just liquidate
the crap and put it in my account but
the money in my account will have a
closing
okay great it's really it's really
there's no advantage to you and there's
huge potential disadvantages the
disadvantages is you the gold goes down
three days after you get a hold of it
exactly and you know or worse than that
this guy is not who you think he is and
it's a fraud the fact that he's
presenting this is very weird and that
alone raises a flag for me but you're
you're vouching for the guy I was
getting ready to give you a 25 chance
this is fraud but you've you've narrowed
that down to a five percent chance now
because you're vouching for him but uh
but I'm I'm still not doing it there's
no way somebody comes up offering me
weird crap you know what you know why
stuff seems weird because it's whiz you
know the reason this feels strange is
because it's strange you know and that
that sometimes you just kind of got to
go with that Valerie is in Detroit hey
Valerie welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys thanks so I am 23 years old I
just got my Master's Degree and moved
home I took out eleven thousand dollars
in student loans in hopes that they
would be forgiven of course they're not
um my dad says he'll pay them from our
education savings account but he only
wants to pay the minimum payment since
they're at a 2.75 interest and my
younger brother still has to go to
college so the money will basically keep
growing in those accounts how old are
you I'm 23. okay the educational savings
account is no longer your father's it's
now yours right he's no longer the
custodian he doesn't get to choose you
choose take the money out and pay it off
okay you think I'm positive
even though
you can transfer that money to my
younger brother
you can't transfer the money to your
younger brother you have a debt
what'd you get your Masters in
biostatistics have you gotten a new job
yes big girl Master's job
yes well I'm living at home and I'm
making 80 000. why are you living at
home
because I got the job right before I
graduated so I don't know I'm not sure
where I want to live yet you're not what
she's not sure where she wants to live
oh yeah but you're sure you want to move
out soon yes but you have the job
probably within the next six months to a
year yeah I'm sorry wait a minute you
know where you work right yes
so why do you have to wait to move out
because you know where you work
okay
um
yeah
all right I I would solve that and I
would I it's time for you to be out on
your own it's time for you to pay off
the student loan
okay okay as fast as you possibly can if
your dad's not going to give you access
to this your parents are exercising an
awful lot of control over you for a 21
year old that makes eighty thousand
dollars a year and should be standing on
her own
okay you you're you're
you know it's time for you to move out
and be adulting as they say and uh so
yeah I would get my own place and I
would pay off the student loan and I
would do all of that in the next 90 days
if I woke up in your shoes if you were
my daughter that's what I would tell you
to do I love you and I would love to
have you stay here but it's not good for
you so you get to move out
and I'm sure I'm kicking you out because
you get to fly and be free Eagles to
stay in the nest too long are known as
turkeys so you're you're not a turkey at
all Valerie you're not a bad person
you're a wonderful sweet kind young lady
um but I I want you to have some courage
and throw your throw those shoulders
back and walk into the wind kiddo and uh
fly eagle fly you know she's very sweet
everybody could hear how sweet she is
however
one thing I want to mention Valerie is
that if you go along with this plan this
money that was supposed to be used for
your education and all of a sudden I'm
just gonna donate it to my brother I
would be concerned about resentment that
could creep in and grow and I just don't
think that's healthy and so this is
another boundary issue that Dave's
brought up with you leaving I think
there needs to be a boundary on this if
that money was dedicated to your
education use it yeah yeah and your dad
should just release it it's eleven
thousand dollars and you should pay it
off this
is really by Friday is what you should
do I don't think you're going to do that
because I don't think you're going to
stand up to your dad so
um but but I wish you would
I wish it would I think it'd be good for
him and I think it'd be good for you and
um uh it they're the hardest folks that
heart for her to her dad the hardest
part of parenting is when you no longer
get to tell them what to do
and now you can't use your dad voice
anymore you have to use the older Uncle
persuasive voice because it's the only
one you got they took your other one
away when they left and sorry Dad but
you can't stop it from happening Time
Marches On
time for Valerie to go
that puts this hour the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]